[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants et bien nounours
nous voilà arrivés rue des enfants sages
vas tu dis au revoir à nicolas ya pa pr
neil avant de partir en voyage au trou
[Musique]
mais pardon français à nos chers petits
amis sinon ils ne vont rien comprendre
ce nounours quand même depuis qu'il sait
que nous allons en chine
il passe ses journées avec un
dictionnaire chinois devant la truffe
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce que tu as comme appel ça
veut dire bonjour amis en chinois a dit
dans si tu dois expliquer chaque fois ce
que ça veut dire
et ben duffy la région d'apprendre le
chinois c'est très joli mais seulement
si vous partez ce soir en voyage tu
parles pas encore très bien mon
compagnon par le très bon ami il vient
ainsi la musique chinoise évidemment
vous de la musique de poules pays sur
fond lundi dans illégal est un compagnon
vient bien parler nous
on a préparé quelque chose pour votre
voyage pour ce job petit régal des
saucissons des chocolats c'est bon
voyage nono des bonnes parties et c'est
moi qui m'y leader nazi des plus gros
bonbon tout fort et on vous a même fait
des cafés shah abdul il commence à faire
froid dans le seul cas il est bon
[Musique]
puis le frau mit den borre alors vous
met toute la beauté de votre panier pour
le voyage est aussi ce groupe vise les
femmes mais ne mange pas toucher surtout
vous promet de le partager avec ma forme
et ça c'est pour toi te voilà patron
nous allons le petit effondrement d'un
accompagnement jusqu'à la fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les bonnes annonces jurés les gens là
vous me promettez de trop de nos forums
oui on y reste couché très vite que les
soirs et en fera pas de caprices et
nicolet dessus sera plus violent et
patronales de mettre un peu la toile en
sang mais je laisse mon front je pars 30
j'ai un gros buzz une voyageurs auront
besoin à bientôt
mais fi
[Musique]
oh
c'est promis mes petits amis et si vous
êtes très très sage nous vous ramèneront
une belle surprise à te voilà nounours
[Musique]
l'on ne sois pas triste
on reviendra bientôt tu le sais moi
petit
patron fait moi plus vu chanter leur
votre chanson d'accord fidèles nounours
je suis le marchand de sable
la journée est finie il faut être
raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit tous les
jours sûrement nuage
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage
âge dans le ciel par dessus les toits
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages qu'un mot en
chanter et du haut de mon nuage je serai
mon stable doré
bonsoir les enfants du monde
à demain bonne nuit
moi je continue ma ronde
nuit à tous les oeufs
et mon ami à tous les petits
ce que vous chantez bien à trous allons
en route
au revoir tous nos petits et grands amis
à bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]
ou au